well a walk for a great cause this
weekend and Jimmy Kimmel will be part of
the event here to tell us about the
Southern Nevada walk to defeat ALS is
executive director Don Newberg executive
director of the ALS Association Nevada
chapter thanks so much for being here
thank you so much for having me this is
a really exciting week for us it is and
it's exciting time this is an event that
helps the fundraising for the cause you
serve and tell us a little bit more
about that first off sure we currently
serve about 120 patients in Nevada that
have received an ALS diagnosis we
provide them with care and support we
have a multi-disciplinary clinic we
provide them with things that maybe
their insurance doesn't cover ramps
things like that we also have support
groups there is no cause or no cure for
ALS so that diagnosis is really really
hard on any family and caregiver and so
we're there to step in and help the best
that we can also known as Lou Gehrig's
Disease it is always fatal unfortunately
and
it takes a toll relatively quickly after
diagnosis it does the average life
expectancy is two to five years it does
take a while for the diagnosis to become
affirmative but it is it's a two to five
year life expectancy and you know when
you think about it too it's out of
pocket cause for families about 250 000
a year for all the things that they need
to provide they're just their daily
living needs so overwhelming it is it is
we're so excited to be able to be part
of the organization that we are and
we're so proud of what we do and a great
event coming up this weekend where can
people participate and tell us how they
can do that sure so our walk to defeat
ALS is this Sunday it's at Craig Ranch
Park registration starts at 10 30. so if
you haven't registered yet you certainly
can come and register day of the Walk
starts at 12 and the festivities will go
till about two o'clock we've got food
trucks and we've got face painting and
of course the ice bucket challenge it's
going to be a little chilly but someone
might do it and we've got pumpkin
smashing and just it's just going to be
a great day to bring families together
and we mentioned Jimmy Kimmel is going
to be there of course he's from Las
Vegas but also is tied closely to this
cause he is you know and and do we not
have a wonderful City I mean Jimmy
Kimmel it steps up he has a really close
family friend that's just been diagnosed
with ALS and so November 13th which is
Sunday is Jimmy Kimmel's 55th birthday
and so he has pledged to match 55 55
thousand dollars at our event this
Saturday or Sunday so it's just going to
be so exciting a chance to meet Jimmy
Kimmel as well and support a great cause
and even if people can't make it Sunday
for whatever reason they can still go
online and donate absolutely you can go
on to our website
alsanv.org and you can donate you can
donate to the walk specifically or you
can just donate to our organization well
I hope you have a tremendous turnout I
think you will especially with the star
power there on top of everything else
you're bringing in extra food trucks I
understand we have more food trucks so
that's good
all right Don best of luck this weekend
hope it goes so so well for you thank
you thanks for everything you do sure
thank you for having me all right this
Sunday is your chance to help defeat ALS
it is the walk to defeat ALS happening
at Craig Ranch Regional Park check-in
starts at 8 30 the walk doesn't start
until noon what's that the 10 30 is
checking what did I say 8 30. oh my
goodness you're gonna get there really
early anything 10 30 is when check-in
starts the walk starts at noon if you
want more information you can visit
alsamb.org we will be right back